okay I guess let's get started
so uh in this lecture what we're going
to do is that at the beginning we're
going to talk about uh deep learning
uh especially some of the challenges in
deep learning theory
and then in the next uh probably like
five to ten lectures we are going to
discuss
um different aspects about deep learning
I guess you'll see like over on top of
optimization derivation so and so forth
so uh so basically independent Theory
they are kind of like different aspects
for example optimization which will
spend probably two lectures on later and
uh generalization is another question
which uh we probably
um will talk about for probably more
than three lectures
um and at the end of the course we're
going to talk about some other so they
have different topics
so so in some sense you can view this as
a kind of like an outline for the next
five weeks
um so
so to talk about different Theory I
think it's probably useful to somewhat
kind of like summarize the classical
machine Theory which I actually didn't
really talk about that much
um as you know from a word as view that
much in the beginning of the course
because I felt that you know if it's if
you have too if too much information at
the beginning is probably a little bit
too too much so but now I'm going to
kind of have a kind of a higher level uh
view about you know what classical
Motion in theory
um do in terms of different kind of like
ice packs or different kind of like
topics so I guess uh in the in a more
classical version of theory there are
several
uh things so one thing is called
approximation Theory
so
um so in some sense this another keyword
is called expressivity
our representational power if you see
these kind of things you are you know
that
representational power
so you know that they are all about the
same thing so what they are doing is
really caring about
basically you want to bond
I also the star
which is the best
model in your family
so so far you know until this week you
know we always talk about you know
excess risk we compare it with the best
model in the class and we said that if
you can get the best model in the class
then you are done right but actually
it's not done because maybe you are
using the wrong
uh hypothesis class so your best
hypothesis class in the family
hypothesis Club the best hypothesis in
the hypothesis class is probably not
great right so approximation theory is
basically trying to deal with this right
you are trying to understand whether
your hypothesis class is powerful enough
to express the functions you care about
so for example you know you know you
know kind of shape your case for example
suppose you have some data like this and
right something like this some positive
data some negative data here you know
that if you use linear model then the
best model linear model is not going to
do great right because if you probably
find the best linear model you probably
would do something like this you know I
don't know so so so in this case you
have you you can say that you know I
will say the star wouldn't be great if
you choose your Capital Theta to believe
in your family and and then you can
study you know what
uh hypothesis class can contain a good
classifier even you have access to
population data so and so forth
right so so in some sense this is trying
to understand how good karma hypothesis
class H approximate the ground Truth uh
label function right so
um so um so that's the that's one uh
type of question so um and another type
of question is what we discussed already
so which is about the statistical aspect
aspect
oh sometimes people call generalization
Theory
so so this is about the accessories as
we discussed here in the last
uh several weeks so so you are trying to
bond
from above the difference between your
learned hypothesis
from the best hypothesis to the stock
right so uh and what we have done was
something like
you uh you you bound this by
I'll say the Hat minus L Heights the Hat
Plus
and also the star
minus L height to the star
right so and people have called this
the generalization error
by the generalization error is the
difference between the population loss
and empirical laws on the Learned
parameter right so
right so this is the generalization also
basically the difference between tuning
loss and
test loss right on the learn parameters
if they had this ERM then this is
talking about ER and but maybe in other
cases you are using some other algorithm
to find the hat that you bound the
transition error for that
and this term as we argued the second
term is always small just no matter what
hypothesis class you use you know
basically as long so your loss function
is bonded then this term is always
something like 1y squared and so so
basically that's why we don't care about
this term that much
Okay so
um and
you know what we have done was something
like you prove this kind of
generalization bound of the so you prove
something like I almost had a hat minus
L has the Hat be bonded by something
like some complexity
um
complexity
over square root and I guess typically
probably you should write this
right so and and this the principle here
is that if your hypothesis class is
um
uh is of low complexity that you have
better generalization error
right so so simple hypothesis oh like uh
can generalize better so I think this
sometimes also people call this outcomes
reader
this is I think it's kind of like
philosophical principle which was which
dates back to something like 1100 or
like a some around that time
um and the principle is something like
simple or parsimonious explanation can
generate better to other situations
and you can see even from these two
things where you can see that there's
some kind of like
a conflict or trade-off between the
approximation Theory and the transition
Theory because you know if you use
a very very simple hypothesis class then
your LCL star may not be good enough
right for example for the data I do here
if you use linear model then your LCD
star is not great but your generation
error could be very good because your
model is linear and simple
so so there's some trade-off between and
I think people also sometimes call this
bias and virus right so the virus mostly
corresponds to generalization Theory it
corresponds to statistical
um error introduced from learning
because you have finite data that's why
you have to pay something that depends
on how many examples you have that's the
kind of virus and the bias mostly is the
quality that only depends buys all the
expressivity is the quantity that
depends on the fundamental power of your
hypothesis class is not something that
depends on how many examples you have
right so
um but the buyers virus trade-off thing
right it's it's essentially the same
thing here but the exact definition of
bias and violence can only apply to
basically squares Square loss and linear
model that's why we don't use them
um express it here but the prints for
are some work related
so and you can also kind of like a you
know extend this transition Theory a
little bit by saying that you can have
um you can consider the regularized loss
this is in some sense you can consider
this as a application or implication of
the generalization Theory which says
that if you use regularized laws
by something like
um I'll
I'll hide correct
is something like L has data plus Lambda
R Theta where this is a regularizer
that captures the complexity of the
hypothesis
um so then you can hope to have claim
like this so so you can have a statistic
claim of the following form of course
you know this depends on exactly what
you know regulator use with models so
and so forth but the form of the claim
is something like
if
data along the hat is the global
minimizer
of Il rack l h rack then
you have a generalization Bond
you can bound the excess risk or you can
Bond either I guess either the excess
risk or the generalization error
I guess they are pretty much related as
we have discussed right so all the
generalization error
right so they are bounded by
uh buy something
so this is the top this is the type of
results you probably get uh from this
kind of statistical uh the
generalization Theory because you know
that if you the reason is that if you
optimize this regularized loss and you
indeed find a very small regular slot
that means that your regularizer the r
of theta the complexity
right is small and also it means that
your tuning error is small and then look
if both of these are small then you can
show that your accessories is not right
because this model will generalize to
the the population of the the test case
so uh and and then there's a third
aspect which is called optimization
and the question so far
right so
um there's a third aspect which is
called optimization so the question is
about you know how to
numerically how to
find Theta hat right so the Hat could be
the argument
of the tuning laws or maybe you can talk
about
so they had Lambda the rigorous laws
some characters
right so
um
so and and this is a purely you know at
least in a classical
way of thinking about this you can
basically view this as a separate
question about
you you can forget about where your data
comes from you can forget about you know
why you care about minimizing
instruction loss you just say that I'm
giving extreme laws you know that's my
job right so uh and and typically the
approach is something like you know you
can if the loss function is convex you
use convex optimization
and and all maybe you can use grid and
descent for non-convex functions so and
so forth or maybe stochastic between
descent
um there are many different approaches
um and and when you measure the success
or you match the interface is that you
care about how well
you can approximate the the minimizer
you can never find the exact minimizer
right using a numerical approach right
so you always have some
um uh some small error compared to the
minimizer of the empirical loss and you
can measure the error in different ways
maybe match the error in terms of the
sub-optimality in terms of how different
um your minimizer is in terms of the
loss function compared to the the best
minimizer or you can compare other kind
of qualities
so so in some sense I think
um from this kind of like a
kind of like the summary here you can
think of the statistical part is
kind of pretty much independent from the
optimization part
uh of course they're also you know
interesting interface for example you
know you can also ask about you know
what regularizer so when you write
regularizer right so you can ask the
question you know what regularizer can
equally
can simultaneously have good statistical
performance but also can be easy to
optimize right so and by easy to
optimize it means that you can optimize
it fast or maybe optimize it in a
certain time maybe D time or d square
time so and so forth so there are still
interactions between different parts but
you just need if you just need a
kind of like high level kind of
understanding you can think of the think
of them as kind of separate parts right
the interactions are more on the lower
level
details about you know how do you
achieve the the best statistical
efficiency or how do you achieve best
the best
computational under statistical
efficiency then you have to talk about
the interactions but at a high level you
don't have to think about them uh
simultaneously you can think of them
roughly separately next question is
sorry oh no no this is another reason
sorry my bad this is just the two things
they are there
my my writing is bad so so and these two
qualities are basically similar right so
like you care about the excess risk
which is the most important thing
uh and
um but which is almost the same as the
generalization error right so
um and it actually bounds you bound the
transition everything about excess risk
um
okay so any questions so far so so these
are the the standard way of thinking
about this question these questions
um and but what happens in deep learning
what happens in deep learning is that as
you see things becomes more complicated
and for fundamental reason
um and I think the the first thing is
that for deep learning there are
probably two things that change at least
on the surface so one thing that changes
is that you have you know from linear
model
it becomes non-linear model
right so and this directly affects the
optimization because when you have
non-linear model it becomes non-convex
loss
right but this wouldn't you know change
things you know wouldn't change the the
the structure right like the structure
view fundamentally because it just
become makes the optimization question
harder right so at least at the
beginning this is what I thought you
know five years ago maybe
like more than five years ago when I was
doing started to do deep learning theory
right after deep learning took off right
I thought at very very first I thought
that the only difference is that now
your optimization question becomes
harder so so and then the question is
just how do you optimize better but then
I think in probably like about three or
four years ago people realized that
there's also another fundamental
difference from the statistical
perspective which is that empirical you
you always use this so-called over
parameters model
maybe it's not precise to say that you
always use over parameters model but
generally over parameters models are
better than
um like more parameters are always
generated or almost always better so
more parameters
generally helps
and it can help even to the extent that
when your parameters are more than the
number of data points right so it even
helps when D is larger than and this
still helps
and it even helps when you have already
zero training hour so even after even
after
you already have training up
zero training error
so so this is a plot that uh I
I got from some paper this is a from a
paper by initial by Tommy Collins
Chevrolet next in 2015 so this is what
they've found
um of course this is only a very small
data set but the roughly speaking the
same phenomenon also holds for larger
data sets and you can see here that the
black
curve is the chilling error and the
x-axis is how many hidden units or how
large network is hidden units means the
number of neurons in audio Network which
of course which you know if you have
multiple neurons you have more
parameters and actually it's quadratic
in a number of
the the number of parameters is
quadratic in any neurons in this over in
this fully connected case this is a very
simple fully connected Network on mnist
and you can see that after you have more
than 64 Penny neurons you can fit a
nurse perfectly like zero zero percent
error I think literally zero maybe not
exactly literally maybe 0.101 error
something like that
and and if you look at the a typical
textbook right so you what you will do
is that you would predict that the
the test error will
like go up after a certain points
because you're over fitting you are
using Hue complex of a model and you are
over facing to the data right that's the
purple thing which you would probably
rate from some of the text classical
textbooks and actually it does happen in
in some classical settings but just not
happen often in your networks you know
or probably never happens in life works
and
um
um and and if and what really happens is
the is the right one
the generalization I will actually
continue to improve as you have more and
more neurons even though you are the
even memorize everything right so like
so if you compare 64 versus 4K
basically these are just two neurons oh
sorry these are just two new networks
you know both of them are both of them
have like a face the chain data
with 100 accuracy but one of them has
better test accuracy on than the other
so
um
so so this is the kind of a big mystery
um
um from from a theoretical point of view
especially if you believe in the
classical trade-off between bias and
variants or the trade-off between the
expressivity and the transition Theory
standardization power so
um
so this is a big open question right so
and let me let me briefly this let me
discuss you know like uh again like what
what's the impact on each of these you
know Concepts right and actually you
even have to really think about some of
these Concepts like how to
like this this some of these Concepts
becomes
entangled or intertwined no in deep
learning so first of all for
approximation Theory I think we don't
really change you know things don't
change that much at least
compared to other parts
so for approximation Theory I think
generally I guess you know you know that
you know large models are expressive
and there's actually something called
Universal approximate approximation
theorem
I'm not sure you've heard of if you
heard of it not in some sense this is
saying that if you have a new network
that is wide enough then you can
approximate any functions of course
that's a in some sense a misleading way
to say it because you know
what what does it mean by large enough
right so if you need exponential number
of neurons that's indeed very large that
that's large enough but that's not
really implementable right so so
empirical you don't even need that many
neurons to uh to be expressive I think
you just need a normal number of neurons
but anyway so the the gist is that we do
believe you know regardless of whether
this universe or approximation theory is
exactly answering the question at least
we believe that
um
the new white works are very powerful so
we generally believe that your
the best model in this family especially
if you use a wide enough Network this is
generally small this is what we
generally believe you know
um and at least what you can show is
that so and at least
what you can show is that you can say
this is really small
the the minimizer of the training loss
because if you have a new network with
more than any neurons
so this is just because
with more than a neurons
and is the number of examples you can
you can show proof you can beautifully
memorize all the training examples
at least you can find one network that
memorized other two examples the network
may not generalize but you can but this
already means that your minimum training
loss is very small it's probably zero
okay so basically for approximation
Theory I think we generally believe that
you know
the models are very expressive
and then that becomes the generalization
part
which becomes you know quite complicated
so so there are um there's one another
kind of like a um information about what
practical network uh does is that in in
practice
also people don't use uh very strong
regulations only weak regulations are
weak regularizations are used
and this is kind of like a somewhat
important thing to say just because you
know
recall that you know even in a classical
setting right it's not always that you
can show
um
like like sometimes you know you can
have a work so even in a classical
setting you can have the setting there
where you have a lot of parameters but
you have a strong regularization to
compensate so that's allowed in a
classical setting right for example if
you have a
uh use a sparse in your regression where
you have a lot of features the
dimensional is very high but you
regularize the sparsity of your linear
model then
uh you
are
uh wait I think
speaking of sparse ninja model I think I
forgot to do something that we are left
last time
about the comparison between animals but
but okay let's anyways my back I think I
should have it but anyway but let's
continue with this but anyway so so what
I was saying is that even in the
classical case you do allow to have very
big
uh you do a lot to have D bigger than n
right the dimension can be bigger than I
thought you use the regularization
right if you use it because if you use a
regularization you implicitly
restrict the complexity for example if
you say that the sparse state of your
model is S and S is less than n then
that's okay
so however in in uh in deep learning in
practice we only use very weak
regularization right so typically just
some L2
um at least you know even with L2 you
can work sometimes even without L2 you
can you can work pretty well
and and also the regularization strength
is also relatively small the the
strength is small enough so that you can
still fit your tuning data basically 100
with basically 100 accuracy
so and and another way to say the
weakness of the regularization is that
you can consider the following fact
so the this radicalized laws right if
you just regularize with the for example
you you just regularize with something
like L2
with some Lambda
the regular slots doesn't have
unique
Global minimizer
so or at least it has very different
approximate Global minimizer right maybe
if you really care about the
the numerical Precision right if you say
like you care about the
um like 10 like you care about very very
small you know accuracy you know
Precision that maybe there's a unique
Global minimizer but but for practical
you know purposes you know there are
many different Global minimizers that
are very similar in terms of training
accuracy uh at all in terms of the right
price loss
so and they all have very small regular
slots they have very small uh uh Lots
from the regular regular part they also
have very small loads from the general
airport and there are different global
minimizers
and it's also another thing is that it's
also not true that all of these Global
minimizers perform the same so
This Global minimizers perform the same
on a test
I guess probably it's easier to just
have a figure here I think I did prepare
a figure
so
um so let's see I think
this is experiment I've done
um a few years back you know there are
many different kind of like plots you
can find online on different papers like
this this is just one of them I actually
took a little bit to exacerbate the
differences a little bit but the the
gist is always the same so this is what
this is the c510 and you have two
algorithm
um the the right one or the blue one and
I'm plotting the chain on the test
um and this two algorithms only differ
by the Learning rate they have the same
training objective
they have the same regularizations uh
strengths it's just that the optimizer
are different
so at the end of the you see that both
of these two algorithms formed some
Global minimizer all approximate Global
minimeter you can see the tuning error
is close to zero in both of the two
cases
right under
um so so both of these available mean in
some sense
or at least you know approximately mean
up to very good approximation
but you can see that their tests errors
are very different so that means that
these are two different Global means for
sure right in the parameter space and
also they perform very differently on a
test
so
um so that's the kind of the mystery
right because this kind of refute the
possibility to have a theorem like in
the classical case right so if recall
that in a classical case typically you
have theorem like this where I'm saying
yeah
so you have serums like this
by saying something like if you find a
equal D Global minimizer or a global
minimize or any Global minimizer of the
regular slots then you can generalize
you can burn the joint system
and this is no longer the case because
not all the global minimizers are the
same but some of them are better some of
them are words
and you probably shouldn't have the same
bond for all of them and some of them
probably just don't generate at all
right so this is saying that you cannot
just say any Global minimizer
generalized you have to somehow
distinguish different Global minimizers
found by different algorithms
so so this basically means that you know
and I know and but what what happens
here right so what happens is that
the optimization starts coming to play
and this is the reason so basically as I
allow you to in some sense
like different optimizers found
different color Minima and some of them
are better and some of them are worse
so that is saying that optimization is
not only
so optimization is not only about
of funding
any minimizers and a global mean
if you just say you find a global mean
that's not enough you have to use
optimization to find the right Global
mean
so in some sense the optimization
um
the optimization have two jobs
one thing is that you have to find
something that has smaller error or
smaller a smaller error small
regularized loss and the other job is
that it also has to find
um something I don't know like it has to
find a global minimum
so
so in some sense the kind of the picture
is like this in my mind so you have this
um
um I'm using one dimensional thing right
this is the parameter this Dimension is
the parameter
and basically I'm envisioning this kind
of toy case where you have a the
landscape of the training loss and tests
also cut this right so the training loss
has two Global minimum and and one of
them is a good Global minimum and the
other one is a bad one the bad one in a
sense that the test corresponding test
error is bad
and the optimization algorithm is not
only responsible for funding an
arbitrary Global meaning it's also it
actually has to find the right glow
green instead of the bad global warming
so somehow the optimization algorithm is
doing something beyond what it's
supposed to do
right so I guess uh in some sense you
know this is a one-dimensional case if
you think about the high dimensional
case this is a something I always often
use in my slides it's kind of like your
uh going to a ski resort and
um the first time I came to America I
didn't realize that you know uh you can
have multiple uh values or not much for
parking lots on the same in the same uh
ski resort so I
like when I go back home right I just go
to a I do follow greeting descent right
I just go to an arbitrary kind of like a
valley and I found that my car was not
there and then it's actually a trouble
because the resort is closed and you
cannot lift you up and so so it's
actually pretty annoying but then I
realized that actually there are much
for Global minimum and one of them is
better than the others so so and you
have to find it uh
um so so it's not like arbitrary
um within this set
uh or or or maybe the great intense
doing something more than just the
arbitrary downfield skiing right
um
right so so why the the generalization
so the question is exactly
mathematically where the transition
Theory breaks down I think
um
the bonds becomes accurate you know
basically the bonds you can prove
becomes vectors
in the bound you can prove under this
language under the existing language
becomes vectors
so so basically if you say that you want
to prove a bond that works for all your
network of size 10 million of size like
100 million right for only one million
examples right so if that's the language
you are using then uh it wouldn't work
anymore so you have to have a more
precise way
uh to think about it
does that answer the question to some
extent
right that's that's roughly speaking
that's the approach we're going to take
but there's small there's one problem
with this if you just do exactly what
you said there's a problem which is
you're gonna get the same bound
for any algorithm
right but empirically different
algorithms have different
uh performance you you know and the way
to fix it is it becomes that you first
say that different algorithm
find models with different complexity
and then you can have different bonds
for for them
so so the algorithm has to come into
play in some way so
um yeah so basically that's the that's
the kind of the conclusion here so the
algorithm has to come into play in your
statistical analysis right because if
you don't have the algorithm there you
are not going to distinguish these
different algorithms right so so in some
sense you entangle the statistics with
optimization
um to some extent
and and and uh and and now like so so
basically like the way to fix it is at
least the kind of the current plan that
the general kind of agenda I think most
of the researchers agree on
um seems to agree on uh is that you
analyze the optimization and analyze why
the optimizer finds a good local minimum
so basically you want Optimizer you want
you need to have a theory that says
something like the optimizer
find
a Taylor hat
such that so one they say the heart is a
global mean
that's probably or approximate Global
mean of the empirical risk
and also two
say the Hat has some special property
that you didn't expressly say
that actually should do right for
example the property could be low
complexity
so maybe for example why just to give
you action case for example you you run
algorithm without any regularization but
then magically you say that even though
I didn't let it regularize but actually
the set of height I found has low L2
note
or has the even the minimum L2 note
actually you can prove this kind of
theorems in certain cases
so and then because of the special
property thing and this implies that it
can generalize
right so
um and and people have kind of like
proof theorems of this kind of form in
many different case for example you know
uh like uh
wait
right so so so for example you know you
can talk about ICD right so
um so ICD probably has some you know
special preferences in terms of what
models they want to find uh and maybe
SGD with different kind of like
specifications right so you can have
large and rates you know small batch and
so forth I'll talk about that in a
moment but generally we want to say that
the optimizer the Practical Optimizer
people are using can have some
preferences on certain type of global
minimize
so and then after you have this right
like as I said after you have the the
special preference then you can use the
so this part right from the special
property the low complexity to
generalization this could be kind of
more classical this could be classical
Theory
right or maybe Improvement of classical
Theory depending on what complex measure
you are talking about right as you
suggested
so
um so that's kind of the the kind of
like the
uh the current kind of like uh
statistical of expanding people in
theory
um of course there are other kind of
like approaches but I think this is
pretty much I think kind of like the
high level
people have almost richer consensus on
the high level approach here I think
um um and and what are the kind of the
the the best results let me have a brief
summary of what you know are the best
results people know uh roughly speaking
um in each of these aspects so so
basically first of all for uh
oh okay sorry so let me just make this a
little more formal so I guess you know
um a little more formally
so basically you have probably three
tasks you know in my language
um so first you prove that
I guess you know I'm repeating myself a
little bit in some sense you know so you
prove that the optimizer converters to
uh approximate
uh local
a global mean
of L height Theta
and then in a second task you also have
to prove that in addition to one
to one
the Theta hat
also
has low complexity
for example something like R said I had
is less than c for some complexity
measure
r
and this R depends on the algorithm
depends on even the details in the
algorithm like learning rate in your
batch set so and so forth
and then Tasker 3
you say that for every Theta
such that
R Theta is less than C
and
maybe L height Theta is close to zero so
for every Theta with low complexity and
small Channel error we have
the test error
I would say that it's also small
so
that's kind of like the the general idea
and and what we have done you know what
people have done in this kind of area so
I guess so um
um so regarding the task one
right which is the optimization question
right task one is optimization
so I think maybe if you want to
associate some keyword
to this people would call this the first
question optimization and the first the
second question people often call this
implicit
regularization effect
yeah probably actually explain
this because you know
this is implicit because you never told
the algorithm to minimize this
complexity right it's implicitly in the
optimization procedure and it's a
regularization effect because you get
some low complexity solution
right and the third one this is probably
like the more or less the the classical
authorization block right
and for task one I think
um
what happens is that if you don't have
regularization
so I guess uh sorry so for task one I
think for the optimization question
so one of our search you know consider
the case where you don't have
over parametrization
this is a
over primary physics
you know without over parametrization in
some special case you can still prove
this in some special case
uh for example Matrix factorization
problem
maybe linearizing Network
or maybe something like tens
optimization
um you can show that green descent or
SGD
can converge
to look Global mean
so here linearizing Network means that
you don't have any activations basically
activation is linear so you just stack a
bunch of linear models which doesn't
really have any doesn't really do
anything from a statistical point of
view it's just purely for
for either you only analyze that as an
exercise for for for your Technique in
some sense but you can still publish
papers in it just because it's
everything about opposition is very
complicated
even analyzing linearization work is
difficult
so so this is the one thing that people
have done but you can see that this
doesn't really address the all the
issues right because you don't allow
over parametrization
it only works for linear resume at work
um all Matrix finalization problem like
which is completion so and so forth
so
[Music]
um
and recently you know in the last three
or four years I think so you can also do
this optimization question for
uh for new Networks
for adding new artworks
for almost any networks in your deep you
know shallow so and so forth
um but with the caveat that you have to
of four special
hyper parameters
so special hyper parameters means
something like you know maybe like a so
first of all you need over
parameterization
that's actually probably good because
anyway
empirical people use over conversation
but the limitation is that you also need
special learning rate
or an initialization especially
initialization
and learning rate so and so forth
so
and and that becomes a problem
by the way this is called typically
called ntk approach neurotungent kernel
which I'm going to talk
more in the future lectures
uh and explain why this is called New
retention kernel so this is the
so-called ntk approach
and the problem with this approach is
that this special initialization is a
problem and also Special Olympics or
special algorithm so you also have
something maybe so this is also
you also need something about batch size
for example in most of the paper you
have to like the best sets to be very
big you can only analyze reading design
you cannot have like stochastic building
insects so so this you know
um this is kind of like the the
restriction on the hyper parameters at
the beginning we thought okay that's not
a big problem right we have this hyper
parameters and then next they will
probably extend them to other hyper
parameters
but it turns out that
there is some serious limitation in the
hyper parameters because you know as I
motivated before even you change the
aluminum schedule right you know in the
figure we we found
right so
this one this is a real experiment if
you change the learning schedule you
change the performance of your model so
so it's not all so if you analyze a
special learning rate schedule and you
analyze a special instruction then maybe
you are not actually analyzing uh
anything impressive right so
um so for example like in this ntk case
I think what we can analyze
um the algorithm you cannot analyze
wouldn't give you the best performance
that deep learning offers you probably
get something like 80 on CD far but the
best algorithm probably got like 95 uh
of course you know they are
improvements to uh along this line but
generally the the issue is that you
you make this type of parameter so
special so that you lose
the correct implicit regularization
effect of the optimizers
um and and you are you're analyzing an
Optimizer that doesn't have the correct
implicit organization effect so that
they don't generalize as well as the as
the real deep learning algorithms
but still I'm going to talk about this
because this is a very nice idea and in
certain cases it's pretty useful so
um and then
um for the
impressive organizations question right
so the question about you know why the
algorithm and why the optimizer prefers
certain kind of like a low complexity
model people have had a lot of results
on special cases so special models
or and actually maybe I should quite
simplified models
simply
I don't know why
some somebody took my yoga knife uh Yoga
Yoga break for some reason and I have to
use the book
um anyway uh so special simplified
models and also special
uh optimizers
but here the special business especially
in the right ways you're analyzing the
effect of the optimizer so you
you focus you focus on each aspect in
each paper in some sense so what are the
models that people have analyzed for
example linear regression
this is something you can say and here
you can say that you know certain
initialization prefers certain kind of
like uh uh um models and you can also
talk about logistical question
logistically in your questions
and here you
will see that you know you can prove
something like
even the model just wants to find the
minimum like even the model just try to
minimize the logistic loss actually
tries to find the max margin solution
um so and also for Matrix sensing
a matrix characterization problems
and uh and linear
neural network
so you can you can talk about this and
also there are special aspects of the
optimizers
of course this is a in some sense
there's a sometimes there has to be a
combination of the problem and Optimizer
because you know
certain optimizers wouldn't have
implicit recordization for certain
problems so you can talk about the GD
you can talk about SGD
um
and ICD I think there's actually also
about the the noise covariance
like what what co-virus you will give
you the right implicit organization also
the noise scale
which also matters
and you can also talk about for example
dropout
this is something you you do you know in
your Optimizer which will change the
impressive bias and you can also talk
about learning rate
um which is also actually important
and batch sets you know so and so forth
and and also they are unsolved open
questions for example momentum you know
like specialization all of this has some
in place regulation effect
so that's why this this becomes you know
complicated right so everything you do
in your Optimizer everything you change
right would possibly have an impressive
acquisition in fact sometimes it's
positive sometimes it's negative
of course most of the tricks that we
have seen have positive effect because
that's why they survive and they are
published right so
um
um so so
um that's a stethoscope I guess
and
and they are I'm also going to try to
mention a more General result that we
have
on
like uh me and some collaborators have
done so you can also
try to have more General results which
says something like you know SGD
I'll have Theta is roughly equivalent to
doing gradient descent on L hand filter
plus some log l Lambda R Theta
for some
r
for some regulator R for this system
um this is a result that we can so like
this is the a much simplified you know
the high level idea of a result we can
show but of course there are limitations
right so this this can more General
results have weak weakness in other
aspects
for example you may have additional
assumptions or you can only deal with
certain kind of stochasticity so and so
forth
um but I think from this result you can
see that you know this is kind of the
things that we are trying to do right so
if you do if you add stochasticity then
you automatically implicitly you got a
regularizer for free even though you're
you're often you are using stochastic
within design on the original training
loss but somehow you get off finder for
free somewhere
okay so so I think uh um yeah so so
basically we are going to talk about you
know many of this you know in the in the
next few lectures in the in the future
lectures uh and the the for the for the
task three for the generalization bond
this is uh
um also like uh uh an interesting
question for deep learning because
um uh you also want to have precise
generalization bonds that can be
compatible with the regulator you got
from the previous part right so we have
said that the optimizer has a preference
but does that preference leads to a
better optimization uh that's another
open question right so
um so so for example you can have
like so one of the early like one of the
paper
in 2017 proved that for this
if you use a
this as the the complex Dimension where
AI is the the weights
the weights
of ice layer
so if you use this then you can
guarantee a generalization block that's
one of the early results along this line
um but the problem with this is that
this is not precise enough right this is
still too big too demanding in some
sense right so
um
um
um you sometimes even more precise you
know uh optimizes for example if you if
you can guarantee that I guess you know
I will talk about the limitations
probably uh uh when I really talk about
this but this is still not precise
enough
[Music]
and and you sometimes need more fun
Grant
uh uh more more fungal complexity
measure that is more compatible
more fun Grant
and and also ideally you want something
that can be that is uh
that is the result of the optimizer
right so you want this this regularizer
here to be the same regulator as what
you had in the implicit requisition
effect
so um so that's the that's the third
part
um
yeah I think that's a basically a high
level overview of some of the lectures
we're going to talk about
some of the lectures uh in in the next
few weeks and of course there are other
open questions in deep learning as well
uh for example what's the law of the
primary station right so
um in this in the last in this tasks you
know I didn't mention any of those also
and so forth
um but for those kind of things I don't
think there's a systematic study yet so
that's why we don't talk about them much
for now
um
and I think the for the intermediate
plan I'm going to talk about task three
here first
um because we are in this mode of proven
transition boundary we have talked about
random marker complexity uh so so and
all of this depends on the value more
complexity and you know I'm going to
talk about that first and then I'm going
to move on to the other parts
any questions so far
sorry I didn't hear the question
yeah yeah I got the question yeah so so
the question is whether any of these
results or tasks you know depends on the
data distribution yes they all depend on
data distribution I think
um so all of them assume some data
description underlining so uh some of
them will require something stronger
some some of them
just require some regulatory condition
but but I don't think you can go away
without any data distribution assumption
yeah and some of them have very strong
data description assumption to be fair
and that's actually in some sense one of
the in my opinion that's one of the
uh technical challenge here like it's
kind of like a a startup balance if you
assume too much about data then you lose
the
the realisticness
but if you assume something too strong
then uh sorry but if you receive uh if
you assume too less about data then you
you have some harness results like like
so so certainly without any data
assumption you probably shouldn't
approve shouldn't be able to prove
almost any results here just because
things become simply hard especially if
you talk about off
computational procedure it's very easy
to get into LP heart uh hard instance
so so we need some data distribution
assumption another kind of even more
complex question is that you know how do
you leverage your data distribution
assumption like we don't have a lot of
tools
um so for example if you assume it's
called option then what you know you
know something about you know what's the
moment so and so forth right you can do
some certain kind of derivations
but I don't feel like we use the
even the property precaution
um enough in some sense and and let
along other kind of like data
distribution assumption we don't have a
lot of good tools to use them
um cool so
um
if there's no any other questions I'm
going to move on to
uh the generalization Bound for device
works
so
and you can see that this is still
roughly in the kind of mindset of the
classical setting even the only
difference is that we are looking for
proper complex measures not only the
dimension dependency but something more
sometimes more complicated
okay
and and you'll see that this part is
really a direct extension of what we
have done in the last three weeks
because the tools are shared and and
it's really just that you need more
you need better Tools in something
okay so
um all right so now let's
so talk about the the particular setups
that we can do so we're going to start
with two layers
to learn that your Networks
and then in the next few lectures we're
going to move on to multiple layers
uh and for two layers let's use the
following locations
so let's say your parameter Theta
contains of two parts one part is w and
the other part is u
so w is the
uh the linear the the second layer mu is
the first layer so so
basically on your network F Theta X will
be something like w transpose Phi of
ux where U is a matrix that Maps
Dimension D to Dimension n where m is
the number of neurons
so basically u x will be n dimensional
so this will be M dimensional and you
apply on
um
uh element wise random function so Phi
is element twice
value
functions
so so Phi of a vector Z1 up to z n
is equals to
um basically you apply the answer wise
you get Max
Z one zero
to Max
yeah zero
right so after you apply fee you get MN
vector and then you inner product with W
you get a single scalar so we have a
model that outputs a single scalar using
these two layers U and w
and again we still call x i y i the
tuning data set
um
as usual
Okay so
so our goal is that
we first show
I'd rather Mark a complexity Bond
and and then we also talk about you know
how
is RC Bond
is relevant to
to practice
foreign
okay so and I think for today we
probably wouldn't even be able to finish
number one
um because I'm gonna have actually two
bounce one is better than the other
so
um so here is the theorem for a random
marker complexity bound
so the theorem is that
so suppose
you have a hypothesis class that
consists of models look like this
parameters by Theta where you require
that
the norm of w is less than BW
and Norm of u i is followed by B U I
guess I didn't Define UI so this is uh
let me say this so you
is this Matrix of M by D Matrix and
let's say each of the
rows is U1 transpose up to U
and transpose
right so
um so each UI is of Dimension d
and so that's why
U times x is really inner product of
this uis with x
that's the notation I'm going to use
okay so so basically uis are rows of the
the weight Matrix
so we restricted the W and the normal w
a normal UI to something like b double
and bu
and then we also assume something about
the
the the data has expected two Norm
Square less than C
I guess actually this is probably C
Square
the title here
so and then under all of these
assumptions
you can prove the rather marker
complexity bound
R and of H
is less than 2 times VW
times C
Times Square Root n
over square rooted
so I guess
just a remark is that this is not ideal
bound not a good bound
because
I am shows up
in the bond
and actually it shows up in a wrong way
because it says that if you have more
neurons
you have our response right so this is
this the M shows up in the more
classical kind of sense where you have
more neurons you know you have more
complex models than it's not great right
so but this you know so basically you
cannot use this theorem to explain the
size of deep learning or the over
parameters model because this is saying
over parametric model will have bigger
uh write a marker complexity but you
actually want something that
have you want a bond that is better when
M goes to Infinity in some sense right
to explain the plot that I
I kind of like show here right so you
want that as I'm going to Infinity you
want a better and better Bound in some
sense but this one gives you a worse and
worst spot
but it nevertheless let's do prove this
because this is kind of like a warm up
uh for uh what we will show next
I see so maybe let me rephrase the
question first make sure so
so you are
you know
your the question I might if my
understanding is correct your question
is that why you expect this right one is
going to zero or is decreasing forever
right uh instead of like a really going
up after a certain point right it's just
we don't have enough
um data points right like we didn't run
that very super large scale experiment I
think the answer is that
we do think this is already large enough
for us to to kind of believe that it
will never go up like just because 4K
neurons for this task is really really a
lot like 64 already allowed you to
memorize you typically you wouldn't even
run so many you probably just you know
maybe it will be easier to convince you
if I show you
four up to 128. and and you'll see
something like this and then you ask me
the question I'll show you 128 up to 4K
and you probably would be more convinced
um so but yeah but 4K is already pretty
large I think
um that's yeah
um
but of course you can never rule all the
possibility that after you know maybe a
million neurons it goes up it just
sounds unlikely yeah
is
um
right right
so so I guess the uh
I think the intention of the question
was that whether this Bond really is
growing as I'm goes to Infinity right so
because BW could be
both BW and B you could depend on l and
maybe they depend on in different ways
maybe BW increase as M goes to infinity
and B U probably decrease as M goes to
Infinity so that's definitely a
possibility right so I think the thing
here is that I'm choosing this scaling
so that
is at least arguably fun to choose to
think of BW and bu to be constant
um so why the reason is that
this is only this is probably a little
bit big so the UI is the is the
contribution of each component
right so so the
so in some sense the
so I'm choating so but W is the
contribution of all the components so in
some sense you are saying that the top
layer you control the contribution from
all the components and you want to say
that that's the constant you don't want
that to grow as M goes to Infinity
because
because so basically maybe maybe one way
to think about this is the falling so if
you think about the scale the sale here
does make some sense because UI is on
all the flexible constants
then UI transpose
at least at least a constant doesn't
depend on M right so UI doesn't depend
on M
and the UI transpose X doesn't depend on
M
if here I'm writing this a little bit
um I'm not you so here Theta could
probably have some dependency on D we
only care about dependency on let's say
see UI is a lot of constant and then you
have sum of w
uh WI
fee of UI transpose X right so each of
these term is on out of constant and
your wi the total contribution is
constant so so that's why the total
thing you can sum would be if that this
is on the order of constants
because it's not like each of the wi is
a lot of constant it's the the sum of
the squares of them is on all of
constants so in some sense you can
believe that this whole thing is on auto
constant
especially if you have
uh I guess it depends on how you think
about this right so if you Subs replace
W I by One V squared and then this is
actually
this is let's see so this is a
I guess depending on how you approximate
this like a roughly speaking if you if
you use caution shorts you're gonna pop
up approximately by something like sum
of wi squared a half times sum of UI
transpose x square
a half
and and this is something
uh let me see
why this is not of cons maybe maybe
we're actually even more generous than
that so
but
the L2 Norm of w is a constant
but
but I think you can still make this
bigger
if all of them are correlated right so
if
others
okay so I think this is
I'm pretty sure the answer I should have
answered but I'm not
I don't see I have a common sensor right
now so maybe we can discuss offline
performance yeah
um but I think the scaling is chosen to
be at least you know reasonably correct
you know of course you can still argue
with certain like there are there's
always a
for example depending on how double the
correlates with this race there's always
some kind of like uh flexibility but but
I think the scaling is relatively okay
um
um anyway but but it's a very good
question because you can have misleading
results you know if you don't you are
not very careful about the scale
um Okay so
let's see
okay so maybe I have 15 minutes I think
I can prove the theorem
um in 15 minutes
so
so what we do is that we use the
definition of the writer marker
complexity and gradually pay off the
soup so like we did before right we have
a soup and we have to somehow get rid of
it
[Music]
um
[Music]
but you know compare that activity that
you normally which is different bypasses
right uh but Difference by square um so
that's why I got I don't know
I was I was thinking to use the argument
but I think it's not going to be right
because some of WIP of
UI transpose X I think
the most pessimistic bone right would be
something like
this is less than if you replace each of
the wi by one over Square than and each
of these by a constant you're going to
have some of this
and this will be square gun
so so then in some sense this is not
helping me to justify to use this game
so right but if you believe that there's
some cancellation
so suppose you believe that there's a
cancellation here
then this wouldn't be this would be
something out of
one
so so basically if you want to so if you
believe in there is a cancellation then
it's in this original scaling
um or in other words suppose you want to
make the scaling even smaller
right suppose you want to say that I'm
going to be BW is even smaller than
the scaling I give right or bu is even
smaller then you have to
assume there's a strong correlation in
your model
otherwise your model wouldn't even opt
to put something out of what
so so whether you are willing to do that
so for example suppose I I I I tell you
that this is actually experience things
right so then I have to convince you
that I can choose b w to be on the order
of maybe
maybe one and then UI to be on the other
one was called
and and then this wouldn't go the bound
would indeed would not
grow if I'm goes to Infinity but
you'll find that some of bif of UI
transpose X is very difficult to be big
you have to kind of match up everything
to make it big enough to fit a label so
would you be willing to do that I think
you can arguably say that that's not
are really realistic
Okay cool so I guess let's
uh um let's prove this
so the proof as I said we're gonna try
to remove the soup in the definition of
the random R complexity kind of like
step by step
so first of all let's define
let's define v
to be the
post activation the intermediate layer
right expand V to be U times x which is
the arm dimensional vector
and you can also correspondingly Define
VI to be
the corresponding you know activation
for the is example this is an dimension
and then using this notation the random
marker complex the
only empirical sampling program number
complexity is you take expectation the
randomness is from Sigma
and you take Soup
um you have some of
Sigma I
transpose times huge right outside of x
i
but I've said of x i I'm going to
rewrite it as W transpose bi because
um
just because that's the notation right
so
um let me just replace this here
W transpose VI this is afternoon of x i
and then here you take two over two
things over both W and U and U is the
dependency on U is heading v i
and let's clean up this to put the wire
on your front and you have soup
over
you and soup over w
transpose times y Over N times sum of
Sigma
i v i
I guess this probably looks familiar
for you because we did something like
this in the linear case as well
and then you can get rid of the W but
you still have the U
so you soup over you and you get rid of
the w w has L2 Norm Bond so
is less than BW right so you get
the soup of this is equals to BW times
the L2 Norm
of Sigma i v i
right okay so so now we're getting rid
of that BW we can put BW in front
and now let's
deal with the U
and the U is something like
wait
I think I shouldn't have already here
anymore my bad
so now
let's this is I've this is a sum from
one two and
and let's rewrite this let's plug in
back the definition of VI which is Phi
of u x i
and
um what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to do a kind of like a if you kind
of get familiar with this right you can
see that this is a very loose way to do
this I'm going to replace the two Norm
by Infinity Norm
so I'm going to say that
this is less than square root and
times the infinity Norm of this
this is just because you know
and then back to V2 Norm is less than
squared M times the infinite
and
right so if V is in M dimensional
okay so
um and now the reason why I want to
replace it by Infinity Norm is can be
seen later because missing no because
somehow with infinite Norm I can
simplify the soup
so now I have a soup
and
note that what this Vector is this
Vector maybe let's
do something here so this is a
this Vector is a sum of
a bunch of vectors right the infinite
Norm is about the dimension the
coordinates of this vector
so basically uh
each of this Dimensions is really
something like sum of Sigma I
v u j x i
and the sum is over I
this is the this is the JS dimension of
this vector
so
basically I can take sub over J
and soup over
uh U and
sum of Sigma I
fee u j transpose x i
want
all right and now I can actually also
write u j here because if I take the
Super over J you know the J is actually
only depends on u j
to
um right and
and that's actually
kind of the main reason why we want to
use this input now because once you
write this you found that all the Js are
equivalent right so uh like uh like
anyway you're taking soup right so it
doesn't matter what is UJ or you want U2
right so the soup is the same
so this is equals to
foreign
oh sorry this is an inequality
so
soup over you a single Vector U so you
replace u j b by uh and you say that
this is needs to be needs to less than b
u because u j
you used to have a bond du right let's
just skip it for Simplicity so and then
you can write this as
i v of
huge transpose x i
in some sense you remove the IM
dependency because for Infinity Norm the
how many arms don't matter
doesn't matter so and now
there is one step where I'm going to
remove the
the absolute value
um because if you don't have the
absolute values it's kind of like you
know let's first remove it so by
removing it require will pay your Factor
two and this requires something
that is not exactly civil but I will not
prove it in inches of time at least
so you can remove this
absolute value the reason you know it's
intellectual nodes the reason is
actually you know fundamentally it's
pretty simple it's just basically
because
the the soup is actually mostly positive
like almost always positive
like uh like because you have can choose
the you it's always possible absolutely
will not wait or without absolute value
it doesn't really matter
uh at least for this case right because
if you are taking a soup right so anyway
it's going to be positive because you
can choose you to be to make this
quantity positive anyway so this is uh
uh what I like this is I will ask you to
refer to the lecture notes to for the
formal proof
um and then now after removing the
absolute value
uh you can see that this is
something like a rather Markle
complexity
of something simple because this you can
view this as your function now
and this is the rather complexity of
this kind of function
but still you have fee on you right so
so that's why we are going to use the
ellipsecon the ellipse is composition
so so this will be less than
two
you copy all the constants
so this is by the Ellipsis
the the I think the Ellipsis composition
or the telegram level
ground level
so I think in some sense you think of
like uh maybe you can define something
like I guess maybe
it's Prime to be the family of U
transpose X
right and then you can also look at fee
of H composed with h Prime
so the random marker of three composed
with h Prime is going to be equals to
is this quantity right so and this is
less than the leftist negative Phi which
is one value
and then you get H Prime which is this
quantity
okay
so that's that's the how we do it and
now it becomes linear so U transpose x i
is is a linear function class and I
think we have done this before so uh for
L2 Norm constant linear class I think
you can get
uh something like this is less than 2
square root um
b u over Square over n
times
sorry this is p w
times b u Times Square Root
sum of x i to not Square
this is just by
uh by what we had for the linear model
oh sure yeah sorry
where'd the two come from
so the two come from
here this this line oh and this is the
something I didn't explain right so like
when you remove the absolute value
so
um
can you get they are exactly the same
uh without looking at two is that a
question
[Music]
I'm
[Music]
I suspect it's possible but I'm not 100
sure so like the proof in the lecture
notes
do does lose two
but it sounds like it's possible right
you can save that factor too
um because the intuition I had doesn't
really tell you why you should lose
anything right so my intuition is that
this quantity is just always positive so
the app's value doesn't matter right so
that intuition didn't tell you why you
should lose the two uh
well I really proved the things I think
at least the proof I figure out oh I
read from the book wait maybe I figure
out myself I lose the two so maybe maybe
it's because I
I didn't do the right thing exactly the
right thing
okay so only
and then the very last step you can take
the expectation of the empirical writer
micro complexity
and this is the expected over s then you
just get
um like what we did before right so the
expectation of this is less than C Times
Square Root and so you get this expanded
by
2 squared m b w e u times C over square
root
that's because you use a conscious words
for for this part this is exactly the
same as what we have done for the linear
models
okay so I guess this is a natural
stopping point
um and next time we're gonna have a bond
that
somewhat improved on this so that you
don't have the expensive dependency on
that
um any questions
okay I guess I'll see you on Wednesday